[Music]
as the sonic picks up his first kill
again like you said he doesn't have to
do much just the water to here and there
and the information gathered it's Rubino
that's now against him and sonic can see
he clutches it out as well they starting
to come alive you know what they say if
you can't do teach or if you're an
esports if you can't play coach but
that's just not true for Zhan
[Music]
[Applause]
a legendary one-point-six player sonic
came out of retirement to be the
backbone of the greatest csgo team in
the world and the craziest thing is he
can still sub in for any of his players
and frag out get out of nowhere shoving
it
Astral's has dominated csgo for the last
couple of years there climbed to the top
was decisive swift and cemented them as
the greatest csgo roster of all time
hell they were the number one ranked
team in the world for an entire year but
behind every great team is a great coach
and if Astralis are the greatest team in
the world that makes sonic coaching
royalty he defies the idea that coaches
are just washed-up players when sonic
subs in bodies hit the on days when he
isn't top fragging the server though
sonic plays a more fatherly role for a
straw list making sure his players know
he's there for them through thick and
thin sunny is very big hat it is a great
coach he takes things loose but also is
very strict when it matters so you know
in a sense he is the perfect coach for
me but back when he was a kid
sonic never thought he would ever use
words like fatherly role model to
describe himself I was saving two lives
pretty much one way I was a bully Hoonah
and an idiot to be honest and one way I
was having this passion for for video
games see back then henrik wasn't really
on Sonic's radar instead he was more
interested in causing trouble at least
until he was 14 and he had a run-in with
the Danish police the specific episode
that led to them can involve us you had
these soft guns it was cool and then we
we were two guys sitting and waiting and
there was like six guys making coffee
tea on a it was like a youth club but
they put up a wall where people could
make graffiti legally because there was
a huge issue back then in the city and
then we took these Afghans every one of
their cans their perfidy cans and some
of them actually thought that it was a
real gun
so they he got some some issues
afterwards but they identified us and
and the police came one day sonic hit
the local internet cafes looking for the
kind of crowd that would be safer to
hang out with one that wouldn't make his
mom worried so
and it worked he fell in love with RTS
games like Starcraft
but then CS came along and it was the
only game anyone wanted to play the only
problem was that Sonic hated it and then
suddenly everyone else on the internet
cafe was just playing couch like one
night I came there and I was like I
hated this game I was more like I wanted
to play these strategy games like real
time strategy games eventually I got
talked into trying counter-strike and I
remember my first round at 1.6 and my
friends were knifing me
I had like two hundred bullets trying to
kill them and I couldn't but as a fierce
competitor who hated losing sonic kept
at it eventually a new internet cafe in
town decided to hold a CS tournament and
while sonic didn't win the experience
did teach him a lot about himself namely
that he was pretty damn good at Counter
Strike and I played there for one and a
half hour and came second and that was
where I started okay I'm I definitely
have some some talent for it and that
one loss was just the first step towards
CS glory it's now all funny
from Sonic poor from Sonic 1 Moremi
sonic quickly became known as one of the
greatest 1.6 players of all time joining
up with MTW a notoriously dominant
Danish roster and picked up win after
win after win so the food as a player
sonic was regarded as one of the best
players he had high skill ceiling great
understanding of the game he was playing
in awesome teams they won a lot of
tournaments and he was one of the
players who stood out in that in those
teams he was always very brainy when it
came to the game no not just in terms of
you know mad understanding or
positioning but but smart when he played
the game a lot of players would come in
and just use their aim and it was a
famous phrase back in the day you all a
no-brain and it comes from that time
because that's what a lot of players
played like there were only a handful of
players who really did truly become
cerebral players and I can think of
players like Tommy for instance BSL and
Sonic while Sonic was on MTW he played
alongside some of the greats guys like
legendary igl Ave and tres one of the
greatest players to ever touch 1.6 his
legendary past isn't lost on his current
team either
I remember watching him play big
tournaments and I almost used this thing
up a long time to run tonight and I was
like I want to be like that guy he was
kind of an idol for I think all of
things Counter Strike but in 2012 Sonic
hung up the mouse and keyboard choosing
to retire and go back to school
unfortunately he knew that getting back
into the game as a player wasn't really
an option for him I could see that it
would take a lot of me to invest in
order for me to just get back to a
decent level which wasn't like
secured in any way so and I also have my
son there so it would require a lot of
my time and I wasn't ready to invest
then I'm happy I made that decision and
because he used to be a pro player
himself the sonic understands the
struggle of his team more than anyone a
coach shouldn't just be there for the
players but also for the for the people
like the person behind they will work
for you if you show passion and if you
work hard and if you care about their
personal life but science contributions
don't just end at moral support
although sonic would rather let his
players do what they do best and just
coach them from behind the seats being
able to drop into the server and frag
out is no small feat for any coach
Sonic's on the OP again just two notes
we'll see we can step up today there's a
nice shot the coach takes that exists
with an aggressive big we said he want
to be capable those sort of shots but
he's proven us wrong I think that
coaches should play also just to
understand the mechanics a little bit
but karma is not it's not the adage a
pill for for people to have substitute
to have an academy team where you can
just get a guy up you have to ask if I'm
out of the contract if a guy gets sick
otherwise I'm the one playing and but
yeah obviously it feels great if I can
if I can make one highlight or two maybe
doing a doing a match it would really
make sonic an effective and respected
team leader is the fact that he never
shines away from protecting his players
rights to work-life balance it's very
hard to go and find someone more
qualified the new sonic would be to be a
coach in the first place
if you were to measure a coach he would
score highly in every single area and
I'm not sure there's many coaches that
can match that today astrologer focus on
making sure its players had a good diet
Arian Fitness regimens a sports
psychologist and supportive coaching
staff so they owe their success to in no
small part
Sonic's leadership it's about giving or
getting some aches to percentages here
and there and if you live properly and
in terms of sleeping ride eating and
exercising then you can I get these few
three to four percentages in there and
despite how much emphasis he puts on
making sure the players have a healthy
work-life balance he doesn't want to get
in the way of his own but I have two
kids and a wife who definitely expect me
to be a father not
just for my players but also for for
them so I need to put in a lot of hours
to compensate for the traveling and when
I get back home so I I don't dare to sit
around the computer after practice just
to play for myself my wife would kill me
if I did that Sonic is a legendary 1.6
player an incredible coach a dedicated
husband and father the dude is
unstoppable you have to get Fred to
Sonic as well
[Applause]
and zonic isn't planning to rest on his
laurels anytime soon either I think I'm
just so much of a winner that I want to
contribute to the team in any way
possible to let them know that I stand
behind them and that I always believe
that we can come back and win I think
that's really important for me the
battle for csgo supremacy will rage on
and sonic wouldn't have it any other way
I feel the competition is in different
way but but about contributing I feel
that I'm some [ __ ] I'm contributing to
the team so and I feel like I'm part of
the team as well so definitely I'm
actually happy about being a coach I'm
not I'm not one of the guys who are like
if I can just turn back time unless I
was having the skills of course I will
and symbol then maybe I would push the
button but but otherwise I'm happy where
I am thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and bring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]